if you thought winter had halted the
flow of migrants risking all to reach
Europe this rescue team will vouch for
the fact it's simply not true
setting off from the mothership
responder they've identified a boat in
distress in the Aegean Sea
[Music]
it quickly becomes clear this is not
just a vessel in trouble but a boatload
of migrants who are drown the first
priority for the rescuers is finding
children who can't survive in the water
for long
[Music]
this woman is seven months pregnant
[Music]
frantic efforts are made to save her two
children as her husband please for the
number of people being pulled from the
water seems endless and it's quite clear
not everyone has survived all around
this boat in the pitch darkness you can
hear people screaming for help
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's impossible to simply stand and
watch when so many lives hang in the
balance
in all three children didn't make it
a little girl aged four and two boys who
were both two years old
[Music]
these youngsters will never know how
close they came on the night their lives
changed forever one of the last to be
pulled from the water was this man
reluctant to give up part of a mattress
he's been hanging on to for dear life in
all 12 adult men five females and three
children were rescued almost all were
syrian survivors are treated for
hypothermia haunted by what might have
been
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but for the families who've lost their
children reaching Europe is now little
consolation
[Music]
Syrian dr. Alan Suleiman traveling with
his sister's son Mohammed described how
their boat capsized abruptly but our
driver was and they identified this man
seen earlier hanging on to a mattress in
the water as the driver of the ill-fated
vessel these people's he told us his
name was Oscar he claimed he was made to
drive the boat the Turkish man said he
was on his way to Greece to get work the
rescue crew from the charity mowers
helped those whose lives they've saved
onto the shore on the Greek island of
agatha neesee the twenty-year-old boat
driver is met by Greek police he
subsequently admitted he never driven a
boat before he's now facing accusations
of the manslaughter of three small
children Lisa Holland Sky News in the
Aegean Sea